.
Stell dir vor, du lebst in den
1980ern und jemand erzählt dir,
dass Computer
bald alles übernehmen werden:
Vom Einkaufen, übers Dating,
bis zum Aktienmarkt.
Dass Milliarden von Menschen
über ein Netz
miteinander verbunden sein werden.
Und dass jeder ein
mobiles Gerät mit sich herumträgt,
das um ein Vielfaches mächtiger ist,
als ein damals
aktueller Supercomputer.
Dir würde das
komplett absurd vorkommen.
Aber genau so ist es passiert.
Science Fiction wurde Realität
und wir denken
gar nicht mehr darüber nach.
Bei der Gentechnik befinden wir
uns gerade an einem ähnlichen Punkt.
Sehen wir uns einmal an, wo sie
herkommt und wo wir gerade stehen.
Und lasst uns über einen
gentechnischen Durchbruch sprechen,
der unser Leben und das,
was wir als normal empfinden,
für immer verändern wird.
*Intro*
Die Menschen verändern Lebewesen
schon seit Tausenden von Jahren.
Durch Zucht
haben wir günstige Merkmale
bei Pflanzen und Tieren vermehrt.
Wir hatten schnell den Dreh raus,
aber haben nie wirklich verstanden,
wie es funktioniert.
Bis zur Entdeckung des genetischen
Codes: Desoxyribonukleinsäure, DNS.
Ein komplexes Molekül,
das die Entwicklung,
Funktion und Reproduktion
aller Lebewesen steuert.
Die Molekülstruktur
enthält Informationen
in Form von vier paarweise
angeordneten Nukleotiden.
Sie bilden den genetischen Code,
die Bauanleitung eines Lebewesens.
Ändert man diese Anleitung,
verändert man
auch das dazugehörige Lebewesen.
Kaum hatte der
Mensch die DNS entdeckt,
versuchte er schon
an ihr herumzubasteln.
So setzten
Wissenschaftler in den 1960ern
Pflanzen radioaktiver Strahlung aus,
um spontane Mutationen
der DNS zu verursachen.
Man hoffte auf die
zufällige Entstehung einer neuen,
nützlichen Pflanzensorte.
Und manchmal klappte das auch.
In den 70ern gelang es erstmals,
Bakterien, Pflanzen und Tiere
durch fremde DNS-Schnipsel
zu modifizieren.
Für die Wissenschaft, die Medizin,
die Landwirtschaft oder einfach,
weil man es konnte.
1974 wurde das
erste genmanipulierte Tier geboren.
Damit wurden Mäuse
zum Standard-Versuchstier
für die Wissenschaft und zum
Lebensretter für den Menschen.
In den 80ern
wurde es kommerziell.
Das erste Patent
wurde für eine ölabsorbierende
Mikrobe ausgehändigt.
Heute produzieren
wir viele Chemikalien
mit Hilfe modifizierter Organismen:
Lebensrettende Gerinnungsfaktoren,
Wachstumshormone und Insulin.
Alles Stoffe, die wir früher
aus Tierorganen gewinnen mussten.
Das erste im Labor modifizierte
Lebensmittel kam 1994 auf den Markt:
Die Flavr-Savr-Tomate, eine Tomate,
die sich viel länger hält,
dank eines zusätzlichen Gens,
das die Anreicherung
eines Fäulnisenzyms unterdrückt.
Mehr zum Thema kannst
du dir in unserem Video
"Gentechnik in unserem Essen"
ansehen.
In den 90ern hat
man sich dann auch kurz
mit menschlicher
Genmanipulation beschäftigt:
Um Unfruchtbarkeit
bei Frauen zu behandeln,
hat man Babys mit DNS
von drei Menschen gezeugt.
Die ersten Menschen
mit drei genetischen Eltern.
Heute gibt es
super-muskulöse Schweine,
schnellwachsenden Lachs, nackte
Hühner und durchsichtige Frösche.
Und zum Spaß haben
wir dann noch Tiere geschaffen,
die im Dunkeln leuchten.
Fluoreszierende Fische bekommt man
in den USA schon für 12,99 Dollar.
Das ist alles
schon sehr beeindruckend,
aber bisher war
Gentechnik noch extrem teuer,
kompliziert
und außerdem sehr langwierig.
Das alles hat
sich schlagartig geändert,
als eine neue Technologie ins
Scheinwerferlicht getreten ist:
CRISPR.
Über Nacht sind
die Kosten um 99% gesunken.
Statt einem Jahr, benötigt
man nur noch ein paar Wochen
für gentechnische Experimente.
Im Grunde kann
nun jeder Laborbesitzer
mit Gentechnik experimentieren.
Es ist schwer in Worte zu fassen,
was das für
eine Revolution darstellt.
CRISPR könnte die
Menschheit für immer verändern.
Wie ist es zu
diesem Durchbruch gekommen
und wie funktioniert CRISPR?
Bakterien und Viren bekämpfen
sich schon seit Anbeginn des Lebens.
Sogenannte Bakteriophagen, oder
Phagen, machen Jagd auf Bakterien.
Im Meer rotten sie
täglich 40% der Bakterien aus.
Phagen tun das, indem sie
ihren eigenen genetischen Code
in das Bakterium injizieren,
es damit unterwerfen
und als Fabrik benutzen.
Die Bakterien geben ihr Bestes,
aber sie sind den Phagen unterlegen,
weil ihre Abwehr zu schwach ist.
Manchmal überleben
Bakterien einen solchen Angriff.
Dann können sie ihre effektivste
Anti-Virus-Maßnahme aktivieren:
Sie bewahren
einen Teil der Virus-DNS
in ihrem
eigenen genetischen Code auf,
in einem DNS-Archiv
das CRISPR genannt wird.
Hier ist die Virus-DNS sicher,
bis sie wieder gebraucht wird.
Greift das Virus erneut an,
macht das Bakterium
eine RNS-Kopie der Viren-DNS
und setzt sie
in eine Geheimwaffe ein:
Ein Protein namens Cas9.
Dieses Protein sucht jetzt
das Innere der Bakterienzelle
nach Anzeichen des Virus ab,
indem es jedes DNS-Stück,
das es finden kann,
mit dem RNS-Muster
aus dem Archiv vergleicht.
Findet das Protein
ein 100%-iges Gegenstück,
wird es aktiviert
und schneidet die Virus-DNS heraus.
Das Virus ist nun
nutzlos und das Bakterium sicher.
Das Besondere daran ist,
dass Cas9 sehr präzise agiert,
quasi wie ein DNS-Chirurg.
Die Revolution begann schließlich,
als Wissenschaftler herausfanden,
wie sie das
CRISPR-System programmieren konnten.
Man gibt ihm
einfach ein DNS-Schnipsel
und setzt es in
eine lebende Zelle ein.
Musste man früher
mit Landkarten navigieren,
dann hatte man jetzt ein GPS-System.
Und CRISPR ist nicht nur präzise,
günstig und einfach,
sondern ermöglicht es außerdem,
lebende Zellen zu bearbeiten,
Gene ein- und auszuschalten
und bestimmte
DNS-Sequenzen anzusteuern.
Und das bei allen Arten von Zellen:
Mikroorganismen,
Pflanzen, Tieren und Menschen.
Aber auch wenn es einen
gigantischen Durchbruch darstellt,
ist CRISPR immer noch
das erste Werkzeug seiner Art.
Noch präzisere Methoden
sind bereits in der Entwicklung.
2015 haben Wissenschaftler
bereits im Labor gezeigt,
dass man mit CRISPR das HI-Virus
aus lebenden menschlichen
Zellen schneiden kann.
Ein Jahr später führten sie ein
größeres Experiment an Ratten durch,
bei denen so gut wie jede
Körperzelle mit HIV infiziert war.
Indem sie CRISPR in
die Schwänze der Ratten spritzten,
konnten sie aus
über 50% der Körperzellen
die Virus-DNS eliminieren.
In ein paar Jahrzehnten könnte
eine CRISPR-Therapie HIV heilen.
Und auch gegen andere Retroviren,
Viren, die sich in menschlicher
DNS verstecken, wie Herpes,
könnte diese Methode helfen.
CRISPR könnte außerdem einen unserer
größten Feinde besiegen: den Krebs.
Krebs tritt auf, wenn
Zellen sich weigern zu sterben,
sich immer weiter vermehren und
sich vor dem Immunsystem verstecken.
Mit CRISPR könnten
wir unsere Immunzellen
zu besseren Krebs-Jägern machen.
Um Menschen für
immer von Krebs zu heilen,
könnte man ihnen dann
einfach ein paar Spritzen
mit eigenen modifizierten
Immunzellen verabreichen.
Die ersten
klinischen Studien am Menschen,
für ein entsprechendes
CRISPR-Medikament,
wurden bereits Mitte 2016
in den USA genehmigt.
Keinen Monat später
haben chinesische
Wissenschaftler bekanntgegeben,
dass sie ab Juli 2016
Lungenkrebspatienten
mit CRISPR-Immunzellen
behandeln wollen.
Jetzt scheint
alles sehr schnell zu gehen.
Dazu kommen genetische Krankheiten.
Es gibt Tausende von ihnen.
Manche sind einfach nur unangenehm,
manche tödlich und manche
bedeuten jahrzehntelanges Leiden.
Mit einem mächtigen
Werkzeug wie CRISPR
könnten wir dem ein Ende setzen.
Über 3000 Erbkrankheiten
werden durch ein falsches
Basenpaar in der DNS verursacht.
Es wird bereits an
einer modifizierten Variante
von Cas9 gearbeitet,
die nur ein Basenpaar verändert
und damit die Zelle reparieren kann.
In 10 bis 20 Jahren könnten wir
damit Tausende von Krankheiten
für immer heilen.
Aber all diese medizinischen
Anwendungen haben eines gemeinsam:
Sie sind auf das Individuum
beschränkt und sterben mit ihm.
Außer sie werden in Keimzellen
oder sehr frühen Embryos angewendet.
Aber das Potenzial
von CRISPR ist noch viel größer,
man hat damit die Möglichkeit,
genetisch veränderte Menschen,
Designerbabys, zu erschaffen und
dadurch den menschlichen Genpool
langsam aber
unwiderruflich zu verändern.
Wir haben schon jetzt die Mittel,
um einen menschlichen
Embryo zu verändern,
auch wenn die Technologie
noch nicht sehr ausgereift ist.
Es wurde bereits mehrmals versucht,
z.B. im November 2018 in China.
Dabei sollen Kinder resistent
gegen HIV gemacht worden sein,
aber die Langzeitfolgen
dieses Experiments
sind noch nicht abzusehen.
Das hat uns wieder die großen
Herausforderungen vor Augen geführt,
die uns auf
diesem Gebiet noch erwarten.
Aber Wissenschaftler
arbeiten bereits an einer Lösung.
Denk nur an die Computer in den
70ern und vergleiche sie mit denen,
die es heute gibt.
Egal, was du persönlich
von Gentechnik hältst,
sie wird auch dich betreffen.
Genetisch modifizierte
Menschen könnten das Erbgut
unserer gesamten
Spezies beeinflussen,
indem sie ihre modifizierten Gene
an die nächsten
Generationen weitergeben
und damit langsam aber sicher
den gesamten Genpool
der Menschheit verändern.
Erst passiert es ganz langsam.
Bei den ersten Designer-Babys
hält man sich noch zurück,
wahrscheinlich
werden hier nur tödliche
genetische Krankheiten eliminiert.
Aber mit fortschreitender
Technologie wird man argumentieren,
dass es unethisch wäre,
Gentechnik nicht einzusetzen.
Denn sonst würde
man Kinder vermeidbaren
Qualen und Toden aussetzen
und ihnen die Heilung verweigern.
Aber mit der Geburt der ersten
gentechnisch veränderten Kinder
wird weiteren Modifikationen
Tür und Tor geöffnet.
Man wird zwar zuerst
noch keine kosmetischen
Veränderungen vornehmen,
aber mit größer
werdender Akzeptanz der Gentechnik
und wachsendem Wissen
über unsere DNS,
wird auch
diese Versuchung zunehmen.
Wenn man schon einen Nachwuchs
immun gegen Alzheimer macht,
kann man auch noch
den Stoffwechsel ankurbeln.
Oder perfektes
Sehvermögen drauflegen.
Oder was ist mit der
Größe und dem Muskelanteil?
Volles Haar?
Oder als besondere Gabe
überdurchschnittliche Intelligenz?
Die Entscheidungen
einzelner Personen
werden große Veränderungen
für Millionen von Menschen
nach sich ziehen.
Das ist ein schmaler Grat,
modifizierte Menschen
könnten zur Norm werden.
Wenn die Gentechnik
zur Normalität wird
und wir lernen besser,
mit ihr umzugehen,
können wir uns auch
dem größten Risikofaktor
für den Menschen widmen:
dem Altern.
2/3 der 150.000 Menschen,
die täglich sterben,
sterben an altersbedingten Ursachen.
Im Moment gehen wir davon aus,
dass altern durch
Schäden in unseren Zellen,
wie Brüchen in der DNS,
verursacht wird.
Unsere Reparaturmechanismen
können diese Schäden
mit der Zeit nicht mehr beheben.
Aber es gibt auch Gene,
die das Altern direkt beeinflussen.
Eine Kombination aus Gentechnologie
und anderen Therapien,
könnte den Alterungsprozess
anhalten, verlangsamen
oder sogar umkehren.
In der Natur gibt es Tiere,
die gegen das Altern
immun zu sein scheinen.
Vielleicht könnten wir uns
von ihnen ein paar Gene leihen.
Manche Wissenschaftler denken sogar,
dass biologisches Altern irgendwann
der Vergangenheit angehören könnte.
Wir würden zwar trotzdem
irgendwann das Zeitliche segnen,
aber anstatt mit 90 in
einem Krankenhaus zu sterben,
könnten uns ein paar Tausend Jahre
mit unseren Liebsten vergönnt sein.
Die Forschung steckt hier
aber noch in den Kinderschuhen
und manche Wissenschaftler
betrachten dieses Ende des Alterns
zu Recht mit Skepsis,
die Herausforderungen sind
riesig und vielleicht unüberwindbar.
Es ist aber denkbar,
dass die Menschen, die heute leben,
als erste von diesen effektiven
Anti-Aging-Maßnahmen
profitieren können.
Vielleicht müsste nur jemand
einen Milliardär dazu überreden,
sich der Sache anzunehmen.
Eine genetisch veränderte Population
könnte auch viele Probleme lösen.
Genmanipulierte Menschen
wären vielleicht in der Lage,
besser mit
kalorienreichem Essen umzugehen,
wodurch man Zivilisationskrankheiten
wie Übergewicht ausmerzen könnte.
Mit einem modifizierten Immunsystem,
das mit einer Bibliothek an
möglichen Gefahren ausgestattet ist,
wäre man immun gegen die meisten
Krankheiten, die uns heute plagen.
Und wenn wir noch weiter denken,
könnte man Menschen für
lange Reisen durchs All ausstatten
und sie sogar an die Bedingungen
auf anderen Planeten anpassen.
Das wäre sehr hilfreich,
um die Spezies in
unserem feindseligen Universum
am Leben zu erhalten.
Es gibt immer noch
einige große Herausforderungen.
Technologische und ethische:
Manche von euch fühlen sich jetzt
bestimmt unwohl und haben Angst,
dass wir bald eine Welt erschaffen,
in der nicht-perfekte
Menschen ausgegrenzt werden
und nur die Merkmale
gefördert werden,
die wir als gesund empfinden.
Aber bedenke, wir leben
jetzt schon in dieser Welt.
Tests für Dutzende
genetische Krankheiten
oder Komplikationen
sind für schwangere Frauen
in vielen Teilen der Welt
bereits zum Standard geworden.
Häufig kann bereits der Verdacht
auf einen genetischen Defekt
zum Ende der Schwangerschaft führen.
Das Down-Syndrom zum Beispiel,
ist eines der am weitesten
verbreiteten genetischen Anomalien.
In Europa werden 92%
aller Schwangerschaften beendet,
bei denen es festgestellt wird.
Die Entscheidung für
einen Schwangerschaftsabbruch
ist sehr persönlich, aber wir müssen
auch der Tatsache ins Auge sehen,
dass wir jetzt schon Menschen
nach ihrer Gesundheit auswählen.
Es macht auch keinen Sinn, so zu
tun, als würde sich das ändern.
Wir müssen also
vorsichtig und respektvoll
mit der neuen Technologie und
den Auswahlmöglichkeiten umgehen.
Aber all das wird
noch nicht morgen passieren.
CRISPR ist
zwar unglaublich mächtig,
aber noch keineswegs unfehlbar.
Es kommt bei der
Anwendung immer noch zu Fehlern
und zu ungewollten Nebenwirkungen,
die vielleicht erst mal
gar nicht bemerkt werden.
Die Veränderung der Gene
bringt vielleicht einerseits
das gewollte Ergebnis,
eine Krankheit auszuschalten,
aber könnte dabei auch ungewollte
Veränderungen verursachen.
Wir wissen noch nicht genug über
das komplexe Zusammenspiel der Gene,
um das zu verhindern.
Wenn es um Menschenversuche geht,
sollten Genauigkeit
und Überwachungsmöglichkeiten
Priorität haben.
Und wenn wir schon über
eine positive Zukunft sprechen,
müssen wir auch noch
ein dunkles Szenario durchspielen:
Denk nur mal daran,
was ein Staat wie Nordkorea
mit Gentechnologie
alles anrichten könnte.
Könnte ein Staat seine
Herrschaft für immer festigen,
indem er seine Untertanen
zu gentechnischen
Modifikationen zwingt?
Könnte ein totalitäres Regime eine
Armee von Supersoldaten erschaffen?
Theoretisch wäre das möglich.
Auch wenn so ein Szenario,
wenn es überhaupt realistisch ist,
noch weit in der Zukunft liegt,
die entsprechende Technologie
existiert schon heute.
Sie hat tatsächlich
so viel Potenzial.
Die Versuchung ist groß,
Genmanipulation und -forschung
mit dieser Begründung zu verbieten,
aber das wäre ein großer Fehler.
So ein Verbot würde nur dazu führen,
dass die Forschung
an Orten mit Rechtssystemen
und Regeln stattfindet,
die nicht unseren demokratischen
Standards entsprechen.
Nur wenn wir uns aktiv beteiligen,
können wir sicherstellen, dass
die Forschung von Vorsicht,
Vernunft, Kontrolle
und Transparenz begleitet wird.
Fühlst du dich jetzt unwohl?
Die meisten von
uns sind nicht perfekt.
Dürften wir in
einer genmanipulierten Zukunft
überhaupt existieren?
Die Technologie ist
definitiv etwas unheimlich,
aber wir können auch viel gewinnen.
Sie könnte
ein ganz natürlicher Schritt
in der Evolution einer intelligenten
Spezies im Universum sein.
Wir könnten Krankheiten heilen.
Wir könnten unsere Lebenserwartung
um Jahrhunderte verlängern
und wir könnten
zu den Sternen reisen.
Unserer Fantasie sind bei
diesem Thema keine Grenzen gesetzt.
Egal, was du
von Gentechnologie hältst,
die Zukunft erwartet uns bereits.
Was einmal Science Fiction war,
könnte schon bald
unsere neue Realität werden.
Eine Realität voller
Chancen und Herausforderungen.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk 2019